THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING, EVERYBODY.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR HEARING TODAY
IN ROOM 2200 OF THE Þ STREET
BUILDING. AND I ASK, WELL, WE
HAVE, A NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO
HAVE COME TO THE HEARING ROOM SO
THAT WE CAN BEGIN OUR MEETING.
AND SO IT'S EXCITING. WELL, WE
HAVE 42 MEASURES ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. ALL OF WHICH ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES AND ALL
MEMBERS WITH BILLS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. BUT WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC ON
EACH ITEM. I ALSO WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT SB 1105 BY SENATOR
PADILLA, WHICH IS STILL LISTED
IN THE DAILY FILE, WILL BE
RESCHEDULED FOR OUR HEARING NEXT
WEEK. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS INDICATED THEY DO NOT HAVE A
FILE ON ANY OF THE MEASURES HERE
TODAY, AND SO THEIR
REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT BE HERE
TO PRESENT TESTIMONY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN, I WANT TO REMIND ANY
WITNESSES TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. SO PLEASE REFRAIN.
REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY IN YOUR IN YOUR
COMMENTS. SO AS WE'RE READY TO
BEGIN, WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. MADAM ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
HERE. CABALLERO. HERE JONES.
JONES. HERE. ASHBY. BECKER HERE.
BECKER. HERE. BRADFORD. CIERTO.
HERE. CIERTO. HERE. WAHAB WE
HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE BUSINESS OF THE
DAY. WE'LL START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE, WHICH IS SB 911 BY
SENATOR CIERTO. HE HAS, WAIVED
PRESENTATION, WHICH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE AND WILL GO DIRECTLY
TO WITNESS TESTIMONY. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HERE TO PRESENT?
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 911? SEEING NO ONE
MOVE. IS THERE ANYBODY HERE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NO ONE, THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING FORWARD AND TESTIFYING.
AND THIS THIS, SENATOR SATO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATIONS. SO THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 911 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON TO SB
916 BY SENATOR SATO, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, AND THE
SENATOR HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANY WITNESS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
916? IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NEITHER, AS I SAID, THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 916 WILL
BE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON. MR, SENATOR SATO HAS
BEEN VERY PROLIFIC, AND MOVED
HIS BILLS QUICKLY. SO SB 920, IS
HERE AS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE AND THE SENATE SENATOR
SATO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 920? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM 2200
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 920 WILL
BE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
SB 932 BY SENATOR SATO. SENATOR
SATO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM 2200 THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 932? IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 932? SEEING NONE,
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE CABINET
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 932 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO FILE NUMBER SB 974
BY SENATOR GROVE. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM 2200 THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 974?
SENATOR GROVE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 974 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 1015 BY SENATOR
CORTEZ. SENATOR CORTEZ HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1015 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1016 BY SENATOR
GONZALES. SENATOR GONZALES HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION AND IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1016?
NICOLE MERRILEES, ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JUAN JOSE MEJIA PALACIOS,
IN SUPPORT WITH SEACM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
OPPOSITION TO SB 1016? SEEING
NONE AGAIN, SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION AND THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1016 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1019 BY SENATOR BLAKE SPARE.
SENATOR BLAKE SPARE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION THÀNH. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1019?
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1019? AS THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE? WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
1019 WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE SB 1098 BY SENATOR BLAKE.
SPARE IT, SENATOR BLAKE SPARE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1098?
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1098? SEEING NEITHER. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1098 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1030 BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO
WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1030?
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1030? SEEING NONE THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1030 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1067 BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL. IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1067? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1067? SEEING NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CAÑADA. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1067 WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE SB 1036 BY
SENATOR LIMON. SENATOR LIMON HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION THÀNH. IS
THERE ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1036? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1036? SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO SB 1036. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. NEXT IS SB 1094 BY
SENATOR LIMON. SENATOR LIMON HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1094?
WELCOME THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS PAMELA
GIBBS, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. OF COURSE, REQUIRING
CIVIC LEARNING ENGAGEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. ONCE IN GRADES
ONE THROUGH SIX AND ONCE IN
GRADES SEVEN THROUGH EIGHT, AND
WITHOUT CREATING ANY NEW
CURRICULA. WE FEEL THIS BILL CAN
BE DONE WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES. SO WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1094? IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1094? SEEING NONE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CABINET CANDIDATE.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, OAN SB
1094 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1246 BY SENATOR
LIMON. SENATOR LIMON HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE TESTIMONY, THOSE
IN FAVOR OF SB 1012 1246. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCCAULEY. ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB 1246?
SEEING NONE, IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1246? SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB. TEN 1246 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE, TAKING UP SB 1056 BY
SENATOR RUBIO. SENATOR RUBIO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1056? IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1056? SEEING NONE, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1056 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1391, SENATOR
RUBIO, SHE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1391? NICOLE
MERRILEES, ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1391? SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1391 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1069 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SB 1069? ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1069? SEEING NO TESTIMONY, SB
1069 IS THE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
IT WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
PICKING UP SB 1081 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA, SENATOR ARCHULETA HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO ANYONE
IN ROOM 2200 THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1081,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. COMPOSITION
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1081. YES.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR DALE
RICHTER. I'M HERE ON MY OWN
BEHALF AS A VIETNAM VETERAN, I
OPPOSED THIS BILL AND HAVING
BEEN DRAFTED, AND IF I CAN
QUICKLY ADD, I WAS AT THE DMV
FRIDAY AFTERNOON. IT SEEMS TO ME
THEY HAVE QUITE THE WORKLOAD
ALREADY, AND THEY REALLY DON'T
NEED ANY MORE WORK ASSIGNED TO
THEM. QUITE A BUSY PLACE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. HELLO, MY NAME
IS KEVIN INSKO. I'M WITH THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB 1081. AND TODAY
I ALSO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER, ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE, SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, THE MILITARY LAW
TASK FORCE OF THE NATIONAL
LAWYERS GUILD, THE ORANGE COUNTY
PEACE COALITION, THE CENTER ON
CONSCIENCE AND WAR, THE SANTA
BARBARA FRIENDS MEETING, THE
LONG BEACH AREA PEACE NETWORK,
THE COMMITTEE OPPOSED TO
MILITARISM, AND THE DRAFT
VETERANS FOR PEACE, CHAPTER 110.
THE AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE, THE SAN JOSE PEACE
AND JUSTICE CENTER, THE
PENINSULA PEACE AND JUSTICE
CENTER, AND THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION, UNLESS THEY'RE HERE, I
DON'T BELIEVE THEY'RE HERE. BUT,
IN A YEAR WHEN OUR STATE FACES A
BUDGET CRISIS AND THE DMV ITSELF
FACES ITS OWN CRISIS, THIS BILL
ASKS US TO USE OUR FUNDS TO DO
THE JOB OF THE SELECTIVE SERVICE
SYSTEM, WHICH IS A FEDERAL
AGENCY. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CAREFULLY READ THE LETTERS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE, BECAUSE THEY
HIGHLIGHT THE MANY POTENTIALLY
COSTLY IMPLICATIONS OF SB 1081.
AND I ASK THAT YOU NOT PASS THIS
BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1081? SEEING NONE. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1081 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER. WELL, SB 1102
BY SENATOR NGUYEN, SENATOR
NGUYEN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
SO WE'LL START WITH WITNESSES
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1102. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1102? SEEING NONE THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1102 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB
1214 BY SENATOR NGUYEN. SENATOR
NGUYEN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION,
SO WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANY, WITNESS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1214? IS THERE ANY
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1214?
SEEING NONE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB 1214,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1104 BY SENATOR
NILO. SENATOR NILO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES PRESENT
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1104? WELL, GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MICHELI, LARA CHAMBER. I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE FOR YOUR,
CONSIDERATION THAT THE BILL EVEN
THOUGH, LIKE, CARB MENTIONS THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO, SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS FOR ANY MAJOR
REGULATIONS. JUST NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSED OFFICE IS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DRAFTING REGULATIONS.
THEY ARE NOT ENGAGED IN OTHER
ACTIVITIES, SUCH AS ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS. IT'S ONLY THE DRAFTING
AKIN TO YOUR OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT, IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1104? IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1104? THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1104 WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. AS I INDICATED
PREVIOUSLY, SB 1105 BY SENATOR
PADILLA HAS BEEN MOVED TO NEXT
WEEK'S AGENDA, SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO SB 1191 BY SENATOR PADILLA.
SENATOR PADILLA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO I'LL ASK IF
ANYONE IS HERE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1191. ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1191. SB 1191 IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1191 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1120 BY SENATOR BECKER SEN.
BECKER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
MADAM CHAIR STEVE CATOLICO,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
NEUROLOGY SOCIETY AND THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY FOR PHYSICAL
MEDICINE AND REHABILITATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITH
THAT OBJECTION, SB 1120 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 1161 BY SENATOR BECKER.
SENATOR BECKER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1161. ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1161. SEEING NONE. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SO SB
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1161 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1164 BY SENATOR NEWMAN,
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1161 64? I'M
SORRY, IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1164? THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
1164 WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. MOVING ON TO SB 1166 BY
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR DODD HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF 1166? ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO, TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 1166? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1166 WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1192, SENATOR PORTANTINO,
SENATOR PORTANTINO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1192? ANYONE IN
ROOM 2200 THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 1172?
AT 1192. SEEING NEITHER. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1192 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1200 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM 2200 THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1200. WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1487 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. IS ANYONE HERE? SENATOR
GLAZER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1487? ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1487? SEEING NO TESTIMONY THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1487 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB
1499 BY SENATOR GLAZER. SENATOR
GLAZER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
ON THIS BILL. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1499? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1499. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1499 WILL
BE MOVED TO SUSPENSE. SB 1205 BY
SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR LAIRD HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1205?
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1205? SEEING NONE THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1205 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 12 1222 BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL. SENATOR
ALVARADO GIL HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1222? ANYBODY HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1222? SEEING NO
TESTIMONY. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, OAN SB 1222 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1261 BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL. SENATOR
ALVARADO GIL HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1261? ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
1261. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 1261 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1297 BY SENATOR ELLEN.
SENATOR ELON HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1297? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OF 1297? THIS TOO
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1297 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE, TAKING UP SB
1480 BY SENATOR ALLEN, SENATOR
ELON HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON
THIS BILL. SO LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
14 1480. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1480? SEEING NO TESTIMONY.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB 1480 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO SB
1319 BY SENATOR WAHAB. SENATOR
WAHAB HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1319?
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1319. SEEING NO TESTIMONY. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1319,
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO SB 1333 BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
SENATOR EGGMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1333? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1333? THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1333 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1397 BY SENATOR EGGMAN,
SENATOR EGGMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL, SO IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM 2200
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1397? GOOD MORNING
, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. JOLIE
ONODERA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO SB 1397. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1346
BY SENATOR BARRASSO. SENATOR
DURAZO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
ON THIS BILL, SO WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
1346. IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1346? SEEING NEITHER THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1346 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1383 BY SENATOR BRADFORD,
SENATOR BRADFORD HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL, SO
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
HERE THAT WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1383. ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1383. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1383 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1385 BY SENATOR ROTH, SENATOR
ROTH HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
THÀNH. SO WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1385.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1385? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1385 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1442
BY SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH SENATOR
OCHOA HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION,
SO WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1442. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1442? SEEING NEITHER THE BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1442 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. ASHBY
AND BRADFORD SEE IT HERE FOR. SO
THAT CONCLUDES OUR OUR, AGENDA
FOR TODAY. I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE AND FOR BEING
HERE PROMPTLY, WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR A LITTLE
WHILE SO THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT ARE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES CAN BE PRESENT AS
WELL. CAN WE TAKE A TEMPORARY
RECESS SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
RECESS FOR FIVE MINUTES.
EXPERIENCE COMMITTEE IS BACK IN
SESSION. AND THE PRESENCE OF
SENATOR BRADFORD IS DULY NOTED.
AND I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR
BEING PART OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
WE'LL GO BACK. WISEMAN MOTIONS
TO SUSPEND AND HIS VOTE WILL BE
RECORDED ON ALL THE MOTIONS TO
MOVE THINGS TO SUSPENSE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND
RECESS AGAIN
WE'RE BACK IN. IN
SESSION IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND I
WANT TO THANK, SENATOR ASHBY FOR
BEING PRESENT TODAY. SO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE SHE GETS RECORDED
AS HAVING BEEN PRESENT AND
VOTING ON ALL THE BILLS. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DID YOU HAVE
ANY PUNISHMENT TRIVIA FOR ME OR
ANYTHING? NO, I SHOULD, I
SHOULD. IT'S A NEW THAT ONE. BUT
IT'S A NEW DAY. IT'S A NEW DAY,
IT'S A NEW DAY. THIS IS THE
SERIOUS APPROPRIATIONS THIS YEAR
. SO MAYBE NEXT YEAR. SO I, WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING, WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA AND THE MEETING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.